to Ukraine now where at least 23 people
have been killed in a missile strike
near the southern city of zamparesia the
regional Governor says the Missile hit a
convoy of Civilian vehicles and the
outskirts of the city both Russia and
Ukraine are accusing each other for the
attack we're live in the Russian Capital
with Muhammad Val but first let's go
straight to Hora Abdul Hamid who's just
outside that city of zaparisia hotter
what more can you tell us about this
strike and reports civilians were killed
well actually uh the local authorities
here in zapparija saying that the number
of debt now has reached at 24. now we
know this checkpoint very well because
it's the uh area where really the people
escaping or running away from occupied
areas like a herzon as far as lugans and
the southern part of japorita which is
under the hands of the Russians now come
out from it is also the same route that
humanitarian AIDS try to go in from uh
family members who are here who are
going back to get relatives who are
still stuck on the other side so it is a
very known Transit Point really for
anyone who is coming out of the Russian
occupied area now this was a very heavy
night here in the parija there were at
least 19 airstrike certainly it's been
on the increase on a daily cases we've
been monitoring that for the past week
or so this is the part of the region
that is not under Russian control it did
not take part in the referendum yet with
this referendum zaparita would have
become a part of Russia so people here
are on edge
all right thank you very much for the
update
in Ukraine city of zapposia thank you
let's go across to Muhammad Val now
who's live for us in Moscow Muhammad
we've been hearing that Russia is set to
formally Annex four areas of Ukraine how
is Vladimir Putin planning to mark this
occasion
foreign
yes Emily uh preparations are going on
for a big celebration uh both inside the
Kremlin and official one and a public
one in the Red Square yesterday the
leaders of the four Breakaway regions of
Eastern and Southern Ukraine arrived in
Moscow and in the afternoon President
Vladimir Putin issued a decree
recognizing the independence of
zaporizia and her son that's a
preliminary step to uh depict what's
going on what's going to happen today as
a as a treaty between Sovereign entities
so zapposia and Herson are considered in
the eyes of Moscow as independent and
now they have the right to sign a treaty
to unify to you to to for unification
with the Russian Federation and that's
what's going to happen in about three
hours from now inside the Kremlin
uh whereby uh this unification will be
sealed signed and that's in the presence
of parliament members and members of the
cabinet and after that President Putin
is set to deliver what's described here
as a historic speech to the nation to
officially announce the reunification of
uh in the in in the in the Russian terms
the reunification of Russia all right
thank you very much for that update in
moscow's perspective Muhammad Val live
for us there